la semaine de négociations est perçu
comme cruciale et décisive dans la crise
ils craignent haine avec tout d'abord un
face-à-face russo américain qui s'est
achevée en fin de journée à genève des
pourparlers sans parvenir à un accord
mais qui prépare d'autres rencontres on
en parle tout de suite avec notre
envoyée spéciale à genève guillemin
aussi bon soit demain vous vous trouvez
donc devant la mission la fédération de
russie qu'est ce qui est ressorti de ces
négociations aujourd'hui
est bien bon soir stéphanie est bien en
réalité pas grand chose à la formule la
plus appropriée ce soir ce serait très
certainement la fameuse expression
anglaise vous savez l'aide se grille
tout design lui convenant de nos
désaccords en bon français en réalité
personne ne s'attendait réellement avoir
résolu ici à genève en 24 heures
seulement l'une des plus graves crises
diplomatiques depuis la fin de la guerre
froide même sergueï ryabkov qui
conduisait la délégation russe
n'afficher à la veille de ces
négociations qu'un optimisme le plus
prudent possible d'ailleurs je vous
propose de laisser le vice ministre des
affaires étrangères russe nous donner
ses impressions à l'issue de ces
pourparlers écouter cette discussion a
été complexe longue
à un niveau très professionnelle
approfondie
concrètes
sans
tentative de
d'édulcorer telle ou telle chose
nous avons l'impression que la partie
américaine
considère les choses avec beaucoup de
sérieux notamment la proposition russe
et a effectué un travail de préparation
approfondie
comprend
vraiment et franchement avancées sur la
crise ukrainienne qu'est ce qui a bloqué
et bien à peu près tout stéphanie on va
commencer par rappeler les positions des
uns et des autres les américains
exigeait que la russie retire la
centaine de milliers d'hommes postés à
la frontière ukrainienne et qu'elle
cesse de qu'est ce que washington
considère comme une agression contre
kiev et moscou de son côté exigeait que
l'otan stoppe son expansion vers l'est
c'est à dire en clair qu'elle refuse
l'entrée dans qu'elle refuse son
l'entrée à kiev donc à l'ukraine comme
nouveau membre et qu'elle stoppe ses
activités militaires aux abords des
frontières russes et je vous propose
d'écouter à nouveau sergueï riabkov sur
ces sujets
donc nous allons favoriser
toute discussion tout
notamment semaine de l'otan pour
formuler ce que nous avions dit en 2008
c'est à dire chez les questions sur
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan
et il avait été dit déjà en 2008 que
l'ukraine et la géorgie ne serait jamais
membres et je pense que si cela est
valide et encore une fois ce sera un
élément positif
nous sommes las de voir
deux cd mauvaise des demies promesses
des promesses non tenues
des
négociations à porte fermée nous voulons
voulons que tout soit validée clairement
souligner est que ces garanties soient
formulées juridiquement et le fait
aucune concession absolument aucune
concession en a été faite par l'une ou
l'autre des parties comme d'ailleurs le
laissaient présager les déclarations
officielles qui ont précédé ces
négociations c'est donc une journée pour
rien
alors peut-être pas tout à fait
stéphanie d'abord parce que vous l'avez
dit il y à d'autres rendez vous à venir
celui de l'otan mercredi à bruxelles et
puis celui de l'eau et ce jeu de l'ol ce
jeudi à vienne et les discussions
d'aujourd'hui seront certainement utile
à ces nouvelles négociations ensuite
parce qu états unis et russie ont évoqué
évoquer d'autres sujets comme
l'emplacement de missiles des manoeuvres
militaires en europe et même le futur
traité start-3 de réduction des armes
stratégiques nucléaires c'était en fait
d'ailleurs l'objectif initial à 1 de
cette rencontre et des précédents
rendez-vous du format ryabkov chairman
ensuite parce que refusé de faire la
moindre concession s'est aussi montré sa
détermination et sa fermeté ce qui est
toujours diplomatiquement très
intéressant pour chacun des deux camps
merci gaymard aussi notre envoyée
spéciale en direct de genève